all your personal data can be bought and
it's not a secret that it can be traded
on both a legal and legal marketplaces
data Brokers and marketing companies
sell your personal data to businesses or
social media platforms sell it to
advertisers the saying if you're not
paying for a product then you are the
product underscores the risks of free
digital Services which often do this
meanwhile there are plenty of dark web
marketplaces where your stolen data can
be sold and business is booming so what
data can you buy off the dark web your
name date of birth and social security
number can be sold for as little as a
few dollars this information can be used
to steal your identity open Credit
accounts in your name and commit fraud
credit card numbers can also be sold on
the dark web along with an Associated
name address and security code we
visited the dark web ourselves where we
were able to purchase the profile of a
well-known blogger for less than the
price of a large Domino's Pizza if you
want to stay ahead of the game and avoid
falling prey to the dark web subscribe